you're asking for me or anybody else to
stay stable in a world that constantly
moves the end you got your perspective
[Music]
what you'll notice where I go here is
there's not many things I believe in
there's just a couple things that are
unbelievably true with the way that
humans interact and the internet and
specifically this device right now have
a very big say in the way that all of us
in this room can achieve our ambitions
whether that's financial or emotional
whether that's for a business or a
start-up whether that's to grow within
an organization or start your own
business so the thing that I've been
chasing since I was a very little boy is
attention to me the only thing that 100%
connects every person in this room is
that we need somebody's attention before
we can tell them what they want whether
we're running for governor whether we're
selling sneakers whether we want
somebody to give us money for our app or
become the mayor of our town no matter
what you do in this room besides all
being human beings the one thing no
matter where you are on your business
journey right now or your life journey
is that attention is the fundamental
asset the amount of attention the end
consumers in Poland give to Instagram
and Facebook are extraordinary the
amount of you and the rest of the
business world here big and small that
are pouring money into it is very low
the Delta is extraordinary and if you
asked me what the number one thing that
excite me tactically out of this talk is
to get so many more of you to spend in
those two platforms for whatever
business ambition you have and so many
unfortunately think that it's not for
them where the platform doesn't have
their customers on it or that it doesn't
work because they've run some ads and it
didn't work and in that misinformation
is all of the opportunity there's
attention people still see commercials
but the amount of people in 2018 when a
commercial comes on that go and look at
this in between TV versus how many
people did that in 1998 in 1998 this
didn't exist you're watching the mean
cooking lady when it goes into
commercial you're watching that [ __ ]
commercial maybe you'll talk to your
parent but maybe you'll cook a microwave
but you're watching in 2018 everybody in
here the second it goes to commercial
grabs this and now this gets the
attention I did a little homework that
commercial in Polish TV has gone up in
price not down it's more expensive not
less yet all of you and everybody in
this beautiful countries attention goes
here it's now overpriced attention I
have never been to Poland before and I'm
so happy to be here I looked at my phone
the entire time I've never been in this
country I wanted to come to this country
because it's so close to where I was
born I got into a car it's the first
time I'm here and outside the fact that
they wanted to show me one building your
main building which is beautiful by the
way besides looking at that building for
13 seconds I looked at my phone the
whole time 20 years ago I would have
watched outside very carefully and
looked at all the beautiful differences
and similarities it but what I also
would have seen was the billboards that
you have on your highways and roads that
billboard used to have more value today
it's gone up in price from 15 years ago
yet everybody here when they're not
driving as a passenger is looking at
their [ __ ] phone my friends
understanding this is very very
important the amount of people in here
who are wasting money in marketing every
day because it used to work is the
opportunity and the danger depending on
how you're navigating your business
your life what used to work is always
the thing that's going to put you out of
business looking backwards allows
somebody to pass you I am astonished by
how many people when they produce
content or the Internet produce it for
their self-interest not for their
audiences I am astonished by how many of
you and I can think about 12 to 15 of
you know I'm trying to see if I can see
any of your faces I was astonished by
how many of you produce content just in
your best interest not in your
audience's it's about you and what
you're trying to sell and for you and
every post and every post and every post
I know it makes me cry she's right the
baby's [ __ ] right just like a tension
supply and demand is everything and if
you're going to be a personal brand or a
coach or an influencer or have an app or
sell something you have to understand in
2018 in a world of Amazon and Facebook
and Instagram everybody's going to do
that there's nothing anybody here is
gonna start that can't be started by
hundreds of thousands millions and tens
of millions of people for the same zero
cost the great thing about the Internet
is that we all can play the terrible
thing about the Internet is that we can
all play it means you have to actually
be good yesterday I was in London a girl
came up to me she stood on stage I was
about to leave but she was very
emotional I wanted to do a nice like
remember she said to me I've been trying
so hard for a year to build influence
you know and I'm like well how old are
you she's like 20 I'm like well what do
you want to talk about well I just want
to talk I'm like why would anybody
[ __ ] listen to you you good and I
wasn't trying to razz her I was trying
to get her to answer a question I've
always felt comfortable producing
content because I didn't
Douce content for the first 15 years of
my career I first built an actual
company I then actually was right about
where the internet was going then
actually invested in Facebook and
Twitter and was right and then I had the
audacity to think that I was worth
listening to
today everybody just wants to be
listened to because they want to get
attention to then sell something
do you know [ __ ] crazy that is you
need to first put yourself in a place to
get the attention I do not want you to
hire a 24 year old from the Ukraine to
run ads for you I want you to figure it
out for yourself
entrepreneurs raise your hand raise it
high and keep it up for a second every
single person in this room who's got
their hand up has to go home search
google and type in how do I run
Instagram ads for a lawyer in Poland how
do I run thank you how do I run Facebook
Ads
for a banker in Poland this thing Google
is [ __ ] crazy I don't know if you've
ever used it it's got the [ __ ]
answers you have to read it
look I'm deaf I'm terrible at reading
and learning terrible but I'm good at
listening so whether you have to read 10
articles whether you have to listen to
10 podcasts whether you have to watch 55
videos on YouTube you have to everybody
who raised their hands have to in my
opinion have to on 25 years of business
success has to learn how to do it
themselves you go into your laptop or
phone and you place the ad you have
somebody record or you write the picture
you have to see it you have to taste it
because if you do not you will be
leaving the biggest opportunity for a
business person human or entrepreneur on
the table since 2001 to 2003 Google and
let me remind everybody here the biggest
advertiser in the first five years of
Google was Amazon the number one person
that put the most money into Google
during the best era was a
company small company out of Seattle
called the Amazon everybody here knows
Amazon right this second for many
reasons Jeff Bezos is an incredible
entrepreneur but do not get it confused
Google advertising was a substantial
reason why the amount of business I'm
doing for vaynermedia and for me by
putting out content on LinkedIn is
remarkable it's really what we dreamed
it could be five years ago could you
imagine if LinkedIn became a business
Facebook it has if you are in the b2b
space here and you are not attacking
LinkedIn by putting out articles videos
and pictures every day you were leaving
money and opportunity on the table
content is the gateway drug to success
in our society content is what makes
people do something you now have the
ability to make it and have happen for
you what you want
it's sitting right in front of you and
99% of you are not making enough of it
I'm making 80 to 100 pieces a day and
I'm not making enough of it there's
nothing else to say I promise you
over the next half decade coca-cola and
IBM and Kentucky Fried Chicken and hard
rock the cafe I did see when we were
driving here and everybody else is gonna
wake up and they're gonna stunned
running ads in Facebook and Instagram
and you're not gonna get in front of a
thousand people I'm pulling for $5.00
anymore
it's gonna cost $80 and the other thing
is everybody here is not going to be
looking at their stream very carefully
as they were today in five years
just like they don't look at their email
as carefully today as they did ten years
ago attention is the asset executing
against it is how you win I really
really really appreciate your attention
and thank you for having me you
basically asked me hey in the fitness
industry a lot of people are being sold
that they can get into shape by not
doing anything I want to get them to get
into shape by actually doing push-ups
teach people how to do push-ups
this there's plenty of people winning on
Facebook that are not pushy
the problem is 98% of people are pushy
that's why you see so much of it yeah
like there's nothing really there's
nothing really coming out of it we feel
that they owe to pushy and we reject it
at the beginning no [ __ ]
so what's what so we have to be pushy
anyway
no you don't be pushy dumb English don't
be pushy don't be pushy how to do it
practically by giving people information
I think I'll give you the answer because
I'm playing around here a little bit and
I think this will make sense to you if
everybody in here thought that they were
a media publisher not an advertiser they
would make different content instead of
thinking you're making a television
commercial think that you're making a
television show got it you're making
commercials on Facebook that's when
you're pushy when you start thinking
about making a show now you're bringing
value entertainment information utility
that's how you do it so basically my
business based on eBay platform and I
know IP platform super well I know that
platform better on which platform EP
eBay yeah I know this platform better
around my girlfriend but at the same
time eBay
it's like living the psycho man you
never know what's gonna happen you never
know what's gonna happen in life yeah
especially with eBay anyway no no it's
what you know well which is why you know
how unstable and how much it moves the
only reason you're saying that is you
have expertise in eBay I promise you you
never know what's gonna happen in social
you never know what's gonna happen in
crypto you never know what's gonna
happen in Madison Avenue and Wall Street
and Warsaw and Silicon Valley you could
get hit by a bus tonight and die you
never know anything okay so I'm gonna go
to question so there are two statements
in business one statement is that we
need to go all-in 100% into it
and another statement is that we need to
create some different of sources
involved go walk your 20 [ __ ] years
old 16 19 23 right bye
you look great anyway thank you both
keep crushing eBay and establish other
revenue streams - so you mean like keep
keep doing on eBay and also establish
Amazon Etsy and so on a hundred percent
thank you
and and you know why right because you
have the time to work ten hours more a
day also do you sit there up shipping
like a long term thing in certain
business yes and the selling [ __ ] will
always be around
sometimes markets are better sometimes
Shopify is better than Amazon sometimes
eBay's better than you know then you
know Craigslist sometimes Facebook
Marketplace [ __ ] will always change eBay
didn't [ __ ] exist 20 years ago you're
asking for me or anybody else to stay
stable in a world that constantly moves
the end
[Music]